elon musk from spacex and starlink and
tesla he is our he is the world's
well as i guess he's the world's tony
stark in essence he is our most
important industrialist and technologist
right now and he is operating outside of
the government trying to get things done
so right now he's got the starlink
system operating in the ukraine so that
people are able to get internet service
and that's not even a perfect system
because then they're worried that the
russians might be able to actually
pinpoint where people are but he's doing
his best to help keep the flow of
information open and the rest of it uh
he jumped on twitter to make a point
about what's going on here with oil and
gas let's throw up that first tweet he
said hate to say it but we need to
increase oil and gas output immediately
extraordinary times demand extraordinary
measures now he went on here's the
second tweet and this is where it really
gets interesting and you can sort of see
someone's motivations every now and
again obviously this would negatively
affect tesla but sustainable energy
solutions simply cannot react
instantaneously to make up for russian
oil and gas exports
that's someone telling the truth
the truth now think about this tesla
michael you just got a tesla last week
how do you like that car
he loves the car okay he loves the car
the tesla is an awesome machine i had a
tesla when i was in la and then we left
it there because they told us we could
get one real quick when we get here
anyway it's supposed to come this week i
love the tesla it's awesome it's truly
an innovative technology and the idea
that you're not so dependent on gas and
all that stuff okay we all know that and
we know by the way that he's gotten
government subsidies and tax breaks okay
fine but what he's saying right there is
hey i'm a guy
that is selling renewable energy cars
electric cars to get us off this oil
stuff however in a moment such as this
i am willing to put out information out
there and say we better start doing more
drilling here we better start unleashing
american energy
which is going to hurt my bottom line
right then less people will need the
tesla if we actually do that he's saying
i will i will put that out there
because there are things more important
than my bottom line that's what an
actual honest
businessman and industrialist and an
american
would say and it's extremely interesting
because the democrats are completely
against this they wanted keystone shut
down which is exactly what joe biden did
right when he took office and they
wanted us more reliant
on we've got this iran deal coming
through as i said venezuela before
you've got pete budage our gay
transportation secretary and i only
mention he's gay because that's why he
got the job talking about how we gonna
have to think about you know getting oil
again from iran and it's like well pete
you know they throw people like you off
cranes in iran but i guess they're not
quite as bad as evil putin right uh ted
cruz he's down with what uh elon musk
said he said couldn't agree more unleash
american energy now you think a guy like
ted cruz might know a little something
about this he's a senator from a small
state you may have heard of it called
texas and they have a lot of something
there called oil
and if we would allow them to do the
proper drilling and again we can always
talk about how we can do all of this
stuff better right we can always talk
about are there ways to make sure that
fracking is completely safe and you're
not causing little tremors or whatever
people are worried about are we doing
all of the things to make sure we're
we're not harming the environment we're
not causing gas leaks and we're not
polluting our rivers and basically
creating the scene from the simpsons
movie can we make sure we're doing all
that stuff yes but right now relative to
what's happening in the world does it
make sense that at any level
we are reliant on anyone other than
ourselves for energy when we have the
ability
to be completely self-sustaining it just
doesn't make sense and it really doesn't
make sense that we would be buying oil
from russia right now and i'm not saying
this is someone that wants to create a
war right there's a war going on whether
we like it or not so should we be
funding the war through oil when we
could literally tomorrow
just start opening up the pipes could we
what should we do what do you think we
should do